[Music]
would you ever do a Christmas
collaboration with Mariah Carey I love
Mariah Carey she can outstand me so bad
though or so good I would really have
trouble keeping up with her vocally
because I think she's spectacular queen
of Christmas right they call me that and
I said no I'll be missed Christmas or
Mrs Christmas or something else
Christmas right who knows Never Say
Never
[Applause]
Dolly isn't collaborating with Mariah
just yet but her new special Dolly
Parton's Mountain Magic Christmas
features some star-studded Talent like
Jimmy Allen Jimmy Fallon and Miley Cyrus
we're also co-hosting New Year's Eve of
Miley Cyrus oh yeah but we talked about
that when she was one of the gifts and
we're going to do some skids we're going
to do some hosting we're going to do
some songs so it should be fun I'm sure
we're going to wing a whole lot of it
which is going to be the most fun but
this is what we love to see
[Music]
what is one of your favorite holiday
traditions at home
well I love to do what every family
loves to do if you are a family you love
to get with family you love to eat your
favorite foods I cook more like Mama
than any of them everybody says because
I still cook with grease and butter and
things that make stuff taste good and my
sisters they try to live a little
healthier but they can still manage to
make you know when I say if you're
cooking Mama's food you got to cook it
like Mama and if you ain't going to I'm
cooking it